news of bankruptcies a multi-billion
dollar firms a bear market and
brokerages halting withdrawals has many
thinking that crypto is down and out but
a closer look at the data shows crypto
investors are still in the game
crypto investors say that even as the
price of tokens like Bitcoin and
ethereum have plummeted and crypto
lending companies have gone bankrupt
they're staying in the market but things
have gotten a bit more difficult I lost
over six figures in the Celsius Fiasco
since the bankruptcy of crypto lending
Network Celsius which once had a
reported 25 billion dollars of assets
investors say it's been difficult to
find lenders that and the crash of Terra
USD one of the industry's most popular
stable coins has many lenders spooked
says Michael sapphy co-founder of crypto
trading firm dexterity capital A lot of
consumer confidence is shaken there were
a lot of retail traders who were heavily
invested in Terror and heavily invested
in things like Celsius who've lost out
big and they're hurting because of it so
we've seen volumes Retreat there those
issues combined with the 60 drop in
value we've seen in crypto since
November have severely decreased the
size of the market
but investors aren't abandoning crypto
even in some of the riskiest parts of
the market data from crypto analytics
from defy Lama show that while the
dollar value of ethereum locked up in
decentralized staking or lending
strategies has fallen by more than 70
billion dollars since November the
actual ethereum held in these strategies
has gone up a D5 llama representative
tells me this definitely shows there are
commitments to D5 projects from
investors who are keeping their funds on
protocols rather than exiting the
ecosystem unlike Banks crypto platforms
don't carry government backstops like
what's provided in the U.S by the
Federal Deposit Insurance Corporation
but centralized platforms are backed by
companies with Charters and licenses
decentralized lending isn't backed by
much of anything so why are retail and
institutional investors still willing to
play in these markets even after Celsius
filed for bankruptcy protection blackfy
was bailed out by FTX and platforms like
Voyager and Babel have banned their
customers from withdrawing their crypto
this is probably the third bear Market
that dexterity has seen it is the
biggest by far and it coincides with
some serious negative macro sentiment
um but we've been to the Cycles before
we know that what it feels like when the
sky is falling and we know things kind
of always work out crypto investors say
these are growing pains and while they
are being more cautious and many have
pulled out of riskier coins and betting
strategies they believe crypto is going
to bounce back although I did have the
Fiasco with Celsius which would make
most people bearish I stayed bullish
because it provided a buying opportunity
which allowed me to increase my crypto
position tenfold that's Jake Greenbaum a
retail Trader who calls himself the
crypto King he said he has two hundred
thousand dollars Frozen and locked up in
Celsius that he hasn't been able to get
back but he's still got the majority of
his wealth invested in crypto and
obviously that would make most people
extremely bearish about what's going on
in crypto but every bearish opportunity
provides a lot of bullish opportunities
as well investors at Big crypto trading
firms like Dexter charity and ARCA say
they aren't packing their bags and
heading for the exits I think what
you're seeing is people believe that
something special is happening here
there's something that is going to take
a long time to play out but it is going
to be meaningful and it's very much
going to be impactful and then the
question becomes if you believe in those
things how do you play it that's Brian
mossoff CEO of ether Capital he says now
it's all about risk management and
companies making sure they're doing due
diligence on the people they trade with
if crypto continues to bounce back it
has seen in recent weeks that Faith
could pay off we may soon find out if
that's enough to keep their investors
and their own Capital safe crypto
Traders seem pretty Fearless it reminds
me of Massachusetts rapper Millies who
says can't get caught in your feelings
gotta take what's mine some people
scared to be successful they afraid to
shine that's all for now I'll see you
next time